peru has been in the u.s market for over
50 years and they continue to make
highly capable
and highly intelligent vehicles
[Music]
hey jc hey burton how's it going what
are you doing you know as a kid i
thought the subaru brat was one of the
coolest car
trucks out there and i know they no
longer make this so i figured to honor
the brat i would assemble the model
well you know funny thing i was a
teenager when that came out and i drove
one did you really yeah
they were awesome well this is kind of
hard to put together though so i got
some people here that can help what do
you think
i'm down for that because it's way too
hard for me when they're doing that
maybe we should update you with where
subaru's at today
the subaru forester i recognize this one
yep jc this is where subaru's come to
you know uh they've come a long way
since that that
and uh the forester uh is is amazing
because they
they have a they have a car for every
budget
isn't that beautiful this is this fits
like a glove burton this is nice
yeah this is the touring model so it's
going to have all the bells and whistles
can i start it up
absolutely go for it whoa
jc right above that screen there that
full color screen
there are cameras that are looking at
you it is a driver
mitigation system that uh if you are
falling asleep
or if you are looking away too long from
the from the road
it's going to warn you and it's going to
try to wake you up oh my god the
technology
i've heard wait i've heard this thing
now with this if you get in it does it
read your eyes and kind of adjust
everything to your settings
it does so it can handle up to five
drivers
and and it'll have five profiles in
there the settings on your stereo
system the settings for your seat the
settings for your mirrors
it all memorizes that for each driver
you don't have to touch anything so
something i notice here too is the x
mode here the different drive features
yes yeah what four wheel drive what do
you have so all wheel drive
this has the dual x mode which means you
can really get
into the rough and tumble with this even
more and it will when you're going down
the hill
it'll actually keep you from uh you know
from speeding up
uh it's a hill descent control we always
talk about the front seat for mom and
dad
what about the back seat for kids and
burton i feel like we got a lot of space
back here there is a lot of stretch out
room in the forester
this is perfect and a couple things i
noticed is first off the fold down
so we put their drinks right here and
then this little console right here
we got ac coming out is that heated
seats as well heated outboard seats
absolutely
and then this is something this is so
brilliant right here it's dual uh we
like phone adapters
powerpoint right power points plenty of
room so we'll be doing a long trip this
summer in the forester
the kids will be nice and quiet in the
back seat burton i noticed something i
pulled into the lot today it's not as
full as it normally is with cars
you're right it's a little lean out
there you know it's the chip shortage
it's a real thing it's effective
production but if you don't see what you
want on the lot
you can either get something from our
pipeline or you can even order from the
factory
you can still get your subaru i like it
your brat's ready yes this looks nothing
like the box
you know they never do i'm going back to
that forester
all right give super of las vegas a call
at 702-495-2100 or visit subaru of las
vegas dot com
and take advantage of the special offer
zero percent apr financing
on select 2021 models for well qualified
buyers through
june 30th las vegas now